in this video today we will dive in
deeper into two
dinosaurs that were seen in the recently
released poster of jurassic world 3
dominion
in the last video we discussed in short
all the dinosaurs that was seen in the
imax preview
of the movie jurassic world dominion
before f9 of phosphorus 9.
and we told you that we would detail out
the morris intrepidus and the
giganotosaurus
so here we are now and we will now talk
about what these two dinosaurs are
and what they have in store for us for
the upcoming flick
so subscribe if you haven't and do hit
that bell button for regular updates
now let's get down with this sickness
in the middle of all that we also see a
t-rex and a giganotosaurus fighting in
the middle of a late cretaceous
background
and the t-rex is killed after a very
short battle we then observe a mosquito
fly in and take the blood from the dead
t-rex
this might as well be the origin story
of rexy and the mosquito in
john hammond's scepter so in the poster
we then see a small dinosaur
which was lightly feathered and it was
in front of a huge jaw which was likely
a gigantic apex predator of the
cretaceous spirit
so even though it might look like a
raptor it wasn't
it was a mauro's intrepidus and the big
one was a giganotosaurus
so let's discuss these two in detail the
morris intrepides
this is a tyrannosauri theropod genus
that lived in what is now utah during
the late cretaceous
period maurice entrepreneurs is the only
species found there
coming in early by around 15 million
years from others
morris is the earliest known
tyrannosaurid from the cretaceous of
north america
morris was a small tyrannosaur with a
tiny body and a weight of around
78 kilograms or 172 pounds
a height of around 1 meter or 3.3 feet
and 7 to 8 feet long
morris had exceedingly narrow foot bones
with
metatarsal proportions that were more
like ornithomimids than other late
cretaceous tyrannosaurus
in the preview and the poster morris
seems to be a feathered dinosaur and
looks to be very similar to a
velociraptor
and maybe even like daniel knickers it
seems to be smaller than the real world
estimates
as it looks to be somewhat in the range
of the real-life velociraptor not the
ones from the movie
maybe around 5 feet long and 2 feet tall
it also has peculiar things that were
recently theorized by paleontologists
such as lips and eyelids the feathers
also look more like thick scrubs of hair
rather than
modern day bird feathers and its
lifestyle habit is symbiotic to the
larger gigantosaurus as
it cleans off the meat stuck to the
lattice teeth much the
same way as certain birds and crocodiles
in modern times
so let's go to the next dinosaur and
this one is the much awaited antagonist
of the new movie
the giganotosaurus this behemoth of a
dinosaur was even larger than a t-rex
and was seen to easily defeat the
original rexy from 65 million years ago
since the rexy we have today is but a
clone of the one that died out
millions of years back and its dna got
sucked by a mosquito
that was discovered by john hammond the
giganotosaurus was one of the largest
terrestrial carnivores known
but its actual size has been difficult
to quantify due to the incompleteness of
the remains discovered thus far
the most complete specimen is estimated
to be around 12 to 30 meters
or 39 to 43 feet long with a skull
length of 1.53 to 1.8 meters or between
5 to 6 feet and a weight of 4.2 to
13.8 tons part of the family got counted
onto sorry day
giganotosaurus is one of the most
completely known members of the group
which includes other very large
theropods such as the closely related
mapusaurus and the carcara dantosaurus
it may have been relatively fast moving
with a calculated maximal running speed
of 14 meters per second or 50 kilometers
per hour
it would have been capable of closing
its jaws quickly capturing bringing down
prey by powerful bites
giganotosaurus is thought to be the apex
predator of its ecosystem
hence the fight between the
jugunatosaurus and the t-rex
would have been like a fight between a
lion and a tiger both large apex
predators similar in most
aspects and the winner would have been
quite a debate
and so that's that what do you think the
movie will be released next year on june
10th
if everything goes according to plan we
will also
delve in deeper into other dinosaurs and
other monster related videos
in the next months so do like for
support subscribe to be a part of the
mind cue family
and hit that bell button for regular
updates on new master videos
right here on minecube till the next one
take care fam